I'm going to take you along my morning workout routine.
Typically, I do the hour before the kids wake up,
and then Daniel takes the next hour.
We kind of tag team on working out in the mornings.
I woke up to a hefty amount of snow again.
It froze last night,
a pretty hard freeze,
so the windshield was solid ice.
It took me a good 10 minutes and to scrape all the ice off.
Then we got going.
The meadow was beautiful this morning.
It was overcasty and really cloudy,
and everything was white.
It was really beautiful.
I love driving by the dairy because, guys,
we are so close to finishing this project.
We should be getting our milk cows early spring,
which is really exciting.
Our winters are really long up here in the valley,
but they're beautiful.
Very long. I got to the gym,
and I am really bad at filming while I work out,
so this was my last exercise.
Today was shoulders.
So after an hour of shoulder exercises,
my shoulders were completely shot.
Like, in a good way.
I'm gonna be really sore from today.
On the way home,
the sun was starting to peak through the clouds,
but it was still really foggy and Misty.
It almost felt like you were actually in the clouds.
It's so beautiful.
But it's gonna be warm today and sunny,
so I'm sure most of the snow will melt today.
We're kind of on the Snow during the night,
but during the day,
most of it melt off.
Haas is, of course,
always on the lookout.
Haases are our Great Pyrenees guardian dog.
He's huge. He's already starting to lose some of his winter coat.
He's very, very fluffy in the wintertime.
And that was my morning gym routine.